The Bourne Supremacy is directed by Paul
Greengrass not Doug Liman who directed
the first film and once again Matt Damon
fills the shoes of Jason Bourne a guy
who in the first film washed up onto a
boat somewhere with no memory and as the
events of that film progressed he
realized that he is actually the most
badass assassin that ever lived and now
armed with all of these skills and some
knowledge of his past he attempts to
piece things together and find the
people who did this to him because now
he has a different lease on life he met
Marie and fell in love with her and now
they're in hiding and even though he's
the same person he used to be mentally
he's completely different he doesn't
want to be an assassin anymore because
as he pieced together his former life he
began to realize that he hates that life
and he wants a different life now but
people are still after him because he's
now left this organization he's gone
rogue there are people sent to kill him
like Karl Urban and now we have an
awesome movies for the warning if you've
never seen the Bourne Supremacy I highly
suggest checking it out you've been
warned Karl Urban kills Murray in the
very opening of this movie and that sets
Jason Bourne on a path of revenge and
from then on he barely speaks a word
Doug Liman set up a great world as I
said in my review of the Bourne Identity
the Bourne Identity to me is more of a
character piece with some great action
sequences thrown in the Bourne Supremacy
is a straight-up thriller there's not as
much character building going on in this
movie it's far more of a revenge movie
in the first film Chris Cooper was
hunting Jason Bourne and Brian Cox was
also involved but their effort was more
of a wipe the slate clean type of thing
they wanted to erase past errors that
they knew could come back on them and
this film Joan Allen's character is
introduced and Brian Cox is still around
and they're at odds with each other
because Brian Cox's character is still
trying to wipe that slate clean he's
still nervous about mistakes he's made
in the past that Bourne could bring to
light where Joan Allen just wants to
find him and wants to know the truth and
she has her own suspicions about what
Brian Cox and his organization had done
in the past and these two going
head-to-head
while Bourne is out there on a revenge
path is actually really riveting it's
one of the things I like more about
supremacy than identity the behind the
scenes stuff of the people hunting
Bourne is far more riveting and
than it was an identity because they
throw in a better adversarial
relationship between Brian Cox and Joan
Allen and these two butting heads makes
it a lot more fun for me supremacy is
really the movie where Damon became
Jason Bourne in the first movie he's
just a guy and you're trying to figure
out why he can do all these things and
so is he
towards the end of the movie when he
learns who he really is we don't have
much time to really spend with him as
that hardened assassin and in this movie
along with the death of the person he
loves he truly becomes that hard
stone-cold assassin that everyone fears
and you can really see that fear on
everyone's faces especially his enemies
and what Greengrass brought to this
movie was an extremely fast pace and a
lot of that is due to editing the median
shot length is very very very small it's
like barely a second or something it's
slightly over a second there are tons of
cuts in this movie and where that
normally annoys me Greengrass captures
beautiful shaky-cam that's just my
opinion some people hate it the majority
of the time I do hate it but I think he
is one of the few directors who's able
to make it work and one of the reasons
that works so well is because of experts
sound design without that sound design
you wouldn't really know sometimes
what's actually happening there's really
just one scene in this movie where the
shaky-cam went way too far for me and
that's the fight scene between Bourne
this other assassin it's really bad
actually you can't tell what's going on
it's acted well you can tell that there
is choreography and that they're doing a
good job with it but the camera is far
too shaky and we'll talk more about that
in Bourne Ultimatum because Greengrass
really really improved that for
ultimatum but here I think he failed to
present a compelling fight scene because
that shaky cam technique did not work
for that but for the car chases and for
the rest of the movie it really added a
riveting sense of realism something else
I loved about all the Bourne movies but
this one in particular is that both car
chases the one at the beginning and the
one at the end use real cars and what I
mean by that is that they're not Aston
Martins they're not Mustangs they're not
GTOs they're not these incredible old
muscle cars or newer muscle cars like
you'd seen a Transformers movie they're
just an everyday car and that brings it
back to that realism I keep talking
about this everyday sense of things that
you can relate to in these big action
set pieces and the final car chase in
this movie is
my favorite of any of the Bourne films
it's absolutely white knuckled it is so
exciting because Bourne is injured Karl
Urban is after him there's that great
part where he takes a swig of alcohol
and spits it in this cops face to get
out of there also this film easily has
the most touching ending of the original
trilogy where Bourne goes to visit the
daughter of the parents that he now
remembers murdering to ask for
forgiveness because this girl has grown
up thinking that her parents killed each
other in a horrible argument but him
giving her that knowledge that it was
actually him changes her entire life and
it's really profound it's a lot better
in my opinion in the ending of identity
and even more touching in the ending of
ultimatum for me the Bourne Supremacy is
just as good as Bourne Identity if not
even slightly better and a lot of that
is due to just how fast-paced and
intense it is there's an amazing foot
chase sequence in Berlin there's two
great car chases and the character of
Jason Bourne is on this intense revenge
pack and you just feel so locked in with
him because you feel that pain of what
he went through with Maree because
you've already seen identity you feel
that relationship brought up and then in
this film when she dies it's so
heartbreaking that you genuinely want
this guy to get some more answers and
it's exciting as hell the Bourne
Supremacy is tons of fun and I'm going
to give it an A it's a damn good action
movie and it surprised me just like
identity did when I first saw it because
I wasn't sure what was going to happen
they were switching directors who knew
where they could take the story but it
was just as good if not better
so did I stay tuned for my review of the
Bourne Ultimatum coming very soon as
well as Jason Bourne at the end of the
month and something special that I'm
working on something very very cool I'm
excited to bring it to you
hello Stefan hey Jon what's going on I'm
coming for you I know you have an
advanced ticket to Jason Bourne
it will be mine goodbye
okay